>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT IT’S
LIKE TO BE TARGETED AND SHOT BY
A MANIAC ATTEMPTING MASS MURDER
AND OUR NEXT GUEST SURVIVED THAT
HARROWING ORDEAL BUT ENDURED
GRUELING RECOVERY AFTER BEING
CRITICALLY WOUNDED.
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE JOINS
US WITH UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE ON
THE FLORIDA SCHOOL SHOOTING, WE
GOT A LOT TO COVER.
I CAN’T BELIEVE WE MISSED YOU AT
MARDI GRAS.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT THERE IN THE
STREETS.
>> Laura: YOU HIT ME WITH A
MEDALLION RIGHT HERE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT THESE KIDS
ARE GOING THROUGH, WHAT THE
SCHOOL IS GOING THROUGH, THE
RUSH TO GUN CONTROL, CHRIS
MURPHY FOR MY HOME STATE OF
CONNECTICUT INSTANTLY GOES TO
THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE AND SAYS
THIS IS DISGUSTING, POINTING THE
FINGER AT NRA POLITICIANS.
>> ANY TIME THERE IS ANY KIND OF
TRAGEDY, IMMEDIATELY YOU HAVE A
GROUP OF LEGISLATORS THAT RUN
OUT AND CALLING FOR GUN CONTROL
IT TO TAKE AWAY THE RIGHTS OF
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
THEY DON’T KNOW THE FACT THAT
PARTICULAR EVENT.
READ THEIR BILLS, THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THESE KINDS
OF SHOOTINGS.
WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO DO IS
PRAY FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DIED
AND THE FAMILIES TOO AND ALL OF
THESE KIDS.
THERE WERE A LOT OF KIDS THAT
WITNESSED THIS THAT HAVE THIS
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
THE PRAYERS HELPED ME
TREMENDOUSLY.
THERE ARE SOME ON THE LEFT WHO
MOCK PRAYING FOR PEOPLE.
>> Laura: IT’S SO TRITE.
>> I NEEDED THOSE PRAYERS, THEY
HELPED ME AND MY FAMILY, YOU
COULD FEEL THESE FAMILIES NEED
PRAYER, THEY NEED HELP.
LET’S GO FIND OUT THE ROOT OF
THESE PROBLEMS.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING THERE ARE
SO MANY THINGS THAT SLIPPED
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
THE TELLTALE SIGNS WERE THERE.
THIS KID WAS THE ONE WE KNEW
WOULD BE A SHOOTER, WHY DIDN’T
ANYBODY ELSE KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> Laura: BILL CLINTON TWEETED
ABOUT THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN,
HE SAID IN TEN YEARS, 94 TO
2004, HE COULDN’T HAVE GOTTEN
THAT PARTICULAR WEAPON, HOW DO
YOU RESPOND?
>> YOU FIND YOUR LAW THAT WAS
GOING TO PREVENT THIS OR THE
NEXT SHOOTING, IT VIOLATED A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER LAWS TOO.
IF YOU THINK THERE’S SOME MAGIC
UNICORN WHILE THAT’S GOING TO
STOP IT FROM HAPPENING, KEEP IN
MIND HE VIOLATED PROBABLY DOZENS
OF LAWS ALREADY INCLUDING
MURDERING PEOPLE.
IT’S AGAINST THE LAW.
THIS IDEA THAT ONE MAGIC LAW IS
GOING TO STOP THE NEXT ONE FROM
HAPPENING, IT’S NOT.
WHAT YOU DO SEE IN COMMON, YOU
SEE A LOT OF MENTAL ILLNESS.
YOU SEE GUN FREE ZONES, SHOOTERS
KNOW IF YOU GO TO A GUN FREE
ZONE YOU’RE THE ONLY ONE WITH
THE GUN.
I HAD TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS
THAT WERE WITH ME THAT COULD
COUNTER THE SHOOTER.
THAT’S WHAT TOOK HIM DOWN, IT
WAS OTHER PEOPLE WITH GUNS THAT
TOOK DOWN THE SHOOTER.
EVERY DAY IN AMERICA THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO USE GUNS TO STOP
CRIMES, TO DEFEND THEIR OWN
FAMILY.
IF THAT’S WHAT OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS WROTE ABOUT THEY BELIEVE
IN AN INNATE RIGHT FOR PEOPLE TO
HAVE GUNS FOR SELF-DEFENSE.
PRAY FOR THE FAMILIES, CARED
ABOUT THESE FAMILIES DON’T TRY
TO PROMOTE YOUR AGENDA IN THE
MIDDLE OF A TRAGEDY.
>> Laura: HOW ARE YOU DOING IN
THE AFTERMATH?
NOW THAT YOU HAVE GOTTEN THROUGH
ALL OF THESE SURGERIES, YOU
STILL HAVE TO USE CRUTCHES TO
WALK.
YOU HAVE SUCH AN UNBELIEVABLE
ATTITUDE, THERE’S SO MANY DARK
DAYS.
IT WAS INSPIRING TO SO MANY OF
US.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IT EARLIE
EARLIER.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PTSD FROM WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> I DON’T.
I’VE TALKED THROUGH THIS WITH MY
SECURITY DETAIL, MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE OUT THERE.
IF THERE WEREN’T OTHER PEOPLE
WITH GUNS TO STOP THE SHOOTER,
THERE WOULD’VE BEEN 15 MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS EXECUTED THAT DAY
AND THERE WEREN’T BY THE GRACE
OF GOD.
THERE WERE TWO MIRACLES THAT
HAPPENED.
I EXPERIENCED SOME OF THOSE.
I DON’T FOCUS ON THE NEGATIVE, I
SAW SO MUCH GOOD IN PEOPLE.
I SAW MILLIONS OF PEOPLE PRAYING
FOR ME THAT I NEVER MET BEFORE.
>> Laura: I WAS ONE OF THEM,
WE HAD A GREAT PRAYER CHAIN.
>> THAT MATTERED SO MUCH BUT THE
KINDNESS OF STRANGERS AND SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
I’M A BIG YOUTUBE FAN, HE PRAYED
FOR ME BEFORE HIS CONCERT.
>> Laura: HE’S A BIG GUN
CONTROL GUY BUT THAT’S GOOD.
>> HE PRAYED AND IT DID MATTER.
THE POWER OF PRAYER IS REAL, I
GOT TO SEE SO MUCH, GOING TO
PHYSICAL THERAPY THREE DAYS A
WEEK.
I DON’T HAVE CONSTANT PAIN, I
HAVE ISSUES THAT I’M STILL
WORKING THROUGH.
NERVE DAMAGE ESPECIALLY ON MY
LEFT SIDE, TRYING TO LEARN HOW
TO WALK AGAIN WITHOUT CRUTCHES.
I WAS A STARTING SECOND BASEMAN.
>> Laura: I PLAYED COLLEGE
SOFTBALL.
>> I WANT TO GET BACK OUT THERE.
I AM BLESSED BY GOD TO BE ABLE
TO SPEND TIME WITH MY FAMILY, TO
BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO WORK
AGAIN.
>> Laura: LET’S TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT HAD FOUR PILLARS THEY
SEEM TO BE REPRESENTED, 800,000
GOT AMNESTY.
THIS THING WENT DOWN IN FLAMES
IN THE SENATE.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS VOTED
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT’S IDEA OF